Wenn er die sache tatsächlich etwas dran ist dann wäre das eine absolute sensation
und wir würden wahrscheinlich schon bald leben auf dem mars finden einige medien hatten gemeldet dass die us-raumfahrtbehörde
bereits vor rund 40 jahren also die nasa bei der viking mission
organische moleküle auf dem mars gefunden habe diese dann aber
versehentlich bei der analyse verbrannt hatte wie genau soll das damals abgelaufen sein und was ist dran an dieser
mysteriösen behauptung klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Das war vor 42 jahren der absolute hammer im juli
1976 landete die berühmte nasa sonde viking 1 auf dem mars einige wochen später
auch ihre schwester sondern die erste erfolgreiche landung auf dem mars überhaupt die mission
bestand aus zwei anbietern die den mars umkreisten und zwei ländern die auf dem roten planeten auf setzten schon beim landeanflug
jubelte das forschungsteam denn der forschung des maßnahmen endlich konkrete züge an dazu der nasa historiker
glencores
das war das erste mal dass wir gute daten bekam zum beispiel aus der oberen atmosphäre
bevor die physik des wiedereintritt sein thema war dann konnten wir sehen wie langsam sich der länder durch die atmosphäre
bewegte wie dicht sie war die temperatur
so dass wir die hitzeschilde besser verstehen könnten vier experimente waren an bord der beiden sonden das ziel der mission
fotos der landesstelle machen lebendige organismen im boden aufspüren und tatsächlich die mission hatte am ende
spektakuläre fotos biologische
analysen und wetterdaten zum ergebnis und sie prägten das bild vom mars wie man es bis in die 90er jahre hatte doch die
eigentliche frage nach leben auf anderen planeten
lieferten nicht die gewünschte jahr antwort die den weg freigemacht hätte für weitere maßnahmen letztendlich
lieferten die vier experimente kein eindeutiges ergebnis zu dieser frage die resultate waren schwer zu erklären und konnten stattdessen
so oder so interpretiert werden
handelte es sich nur um chemische reaktionen im zusammenhang mit dem mars boden oder waren sie doch als hinweis auf
organisches leben auf dem mars zu interpretieren beispielsweise beim stoffwechsel
experimentier gab es bei der ersten probe von viking 1 ein positives resultat
dass die forschungsteams damals euphorisierte der anstieg der zähler deutet zunächst auf einen hohen umsatz wert eines
stoffwechsels hin also wie bei uns bei menschen die verdauung bei der weiteren zugabe von erle lösungen allerdings sank der wert wieder
also leben hätte hier mit einem weiteren anstieg
reagieren müssen dafür war die blind probe unauffällig also doch ein hinweis auf organisches leben auch das
photosynthese experiment lieferte leichte positive
resultate dennoch waren die ergebnisse auch hier nicht wirklich eindeutig der
wissenschaftlichen diskurs über die frage ging weiter jahrelang wurde auch vermutet dass bereits vor dem start der sonde
organisches material der erde in die häfen gelangt war dass es auf dem mars komplexe organische
moleküle gibt das wissen wir mit voller mit sicherheit ja seit
2012 das hatte kurjo city bewiesen der mars rover hatte kohlenstoffhaltigen verbindungen
aufgespürt die als wichtige voraussetzung für leben gelten erst im juni
hatte die nasa gemeldet dass curiosity weitere wichtige bausteine für leben entdeckt hatte die analyse der gesteinsproben
die übrigens auf ein alter von mehr als 3,5 milliarden jahren geschätzt werden ergab wohl auch organische verbindungen wie
mit tier fäden das ist ein hinweis darauf dass die klimatischen bedingungen in der untersuchten meeresregion vor allen dingen milliarden jahren wohl
lebensfreundlich gewesen sein könnten doch das rätsel der wiki missionen von vor 40 jahren ist immer noch nicht geklärt ein
forschungsteam der nasa selbst hat jetzt versucht erklärung zu finden und jetzt haltet euch fest
die vermutung steht im raum dass die eine der beiden viking einheiten tatsächlich organisches material
aufgespürt hatte dieser wichtige fund dann aber bei der datenanalyse in der ferngesteuerten maschine verbrannt wurde aus versehen
ursache für dieses malheur könnte nach ansicht des forschungsteams die verbindung namens perchlorat seien eine art brandbeschleuniger
die chemikalie wird auch hier auf der erde im brandbeschleunigern eingesetzt diese
plaques perchlorat wurden vor etwa zehn jahren auf dem mars aufgespürt und zwar durch die lande sonde phoenix
sie könnten auch dafür gesorgt haben dass sich die öfen damals stärker erhitzt hatten als geplant dabei
könnten sich die empfindlichen proben in den öfen viking länder entzündet haben so dass diese zerstört wurden diese hypothese
bestätigt das aktuelle forschungsteam jetzt dieses szenarios nach ansicht der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler sogar noch wahrscheinlicher geworden seitdem der jüngste mal sommer
2013 nicht nur organische moleküle sondern auch chlor benzol moleküle aufgespürt hatte denn diese entstehen bei der reaktion von
kohlenstoff und präparaten und auch die landeeinheit viking 2 hatte wohl spuren von
benzol entdeckt berichtete das nasa forschung das team jetzt doch so klar ist das ganze szenario
dann wohl doch nicht schlecht schließlich ist immer noch nicht ausgeschlossen dass die öfen mit material von der erde verunreinigt lagen auch diese moleküle
könnten mit den bergleuten reagiert haben ein gegenargument allerdings ist dass die
kohlenstoff artigen substanzen von der erde eigentlich schon bei niedrigeren temperaturen hätten reagieren müssen
ja vielleicht wird uns aber die exomars mission die 2020 auf dem roten planeten landen soll weitere erkenntnisse
dazu bringen es ist also tatsächlich
möglich dass wir schon bald leben auf dem mars
entdecken wenn ihr kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann und geht er die kaputte auto
boxer auf youtube wo also nur manchmal sagen mag oder wozu ein
video auftaucht von am kanal den er abonniert habt und verpasst kann wie du denn über whatsapp der vater der familie
persönlich vor jedem upload vor allen anderen also tag dicht garantiert wenn im video online gilt einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken außerirdisches leben auf dem mars neue indizien bis dann
bleibt dran